hello good people of YouTube my name is
Dave Rubin I am the newest host here at
the Young Turks Network this is the
Rubin report my name is Reuben
it worked it was nice it was me a Ruben
Studdard he works cheaper yet they still
went with me pretty good we've got a
great show for you what we're gonna be
doing here on the Rubin report is hot
topics things that you know about things
that maybe you don't know about with the
group of people that again maybe you
know maybe you don't know but I know
that you should know them think about
that we got a great group three fine
people with us today
Marcellus how are you doing my man Marky
Mark on Twitter I'm very good
welcome get no complaints you got no
complaints and everyone knows that I am
a very very bitter person who complains
about everything but I lead a blessed
life all right
bitter but no complaints good start
navigate not yet Jackie Monahan comedian
and funny lady a raconteur I would call
thank you why are you doing dad I'm
excellent you know life is treating me
very good as well put blessed and
miracles that's two I don't know and
getting there it's Dave Holmes a man who
has one of my favorite Twitter BIOS the
guy from this thing that thing no the
other things or someone just the guy
from the thing in general you know I
mean the guy from the thing you saw it
may be yeah it may be but maybe not who
knows who knows you've been are to be
here well I am graduates on the new show
thank you guys for coming in I'm
thrilled to be doing this with you guys
and what we're gonna be doing as I said
it's hot topics we're gonna be chopping
them up distributing them throughout the
week and we're gonna start with what was
the big story last week of course
involving a glass of water and a man
with a very dry mouth of course I'm
talking about Marco Rubio giving the
rebuttal to Obama's State of the Union
address let's take a look
nothing has frustrated me more than
false choices like the one that
president laid out tonight the choice
isn't just between big government or big
business what we need is an accountable
efficient and effective government that
allows small new businesses to create
more middle-class jobs alright so that
was the swig of water heard round the
world
guys everyone's all over this on Twitter
social media everywhere what's your take
Marcellus you first really good product
placement for Poland Springs
unfortunately they should have maybe
gone with one of the little girls you
know Sasha Malia the Obama girls oh that
they should have just been standing
there no they should have put the bottle
in their hands because I mean at the end
of the day who cares about like some
like that would thank you yeah they're
better spokesmodels all around yeah so
this was a does Marco Rubio not fit with
Poland Springs is that where the product
placement issue is here may I I think
Poland Spring doesn't want to be
associated with panic you know because
that too that that is the content of
every panic attack I've ever had I
always I'm afraid that I'm just gonna
you know I'm gonna have a dry mouth and
I'm just gonna like break down on live
television that dude did it in front of
one of the biggest audiences in the
world Jackie you're a well seasoned
performer nothing ever breaks you what
what do you make of a dry mouth
politician that's keeping yourself
liquid I just chopped away yeah he looks
crazy
doesn't he he looks insane that's like I
couldn't take my eyes off that because
he's not taking his eyes off the camera
yeah it was kind of like porn how much
you [ __ ] do you think was that was that
kind of stiffness that he has to keep
looking at the camera the whole time yet
we're all watching him going man you
need a drink like how much do you think
just the awkwardness of having to talk
to the camera itself the whole time
played into this I can't believe there
isn't like a pill that he could have
taken or spray that would have stopped
that dry mouth in the moment remember
quench go
how very glands going burst in your
mouth yes right in your mouth and we saw
like things that burst in our mouths
yeah one of the things that I thought
was interesting in the fallout from this
thing
Watergate as they were calling it was
that CNN actually I didn't make that one
up unfortunately CNN actually put a car
on that said career-ender what question
mark could this be a career ender and is
that like the point that we're at at
this point where you just you can't
great you know you get a little parched
and next thing you know your career this
is the young star of the Republicans I
mean I guess you know we could talk to
Howard Dean about that who was you know
who was the presumptive nominee of the
Democratic Party a few years ago and
then he made a weird noise with his
mouth yeah and I was a joke you know
it's remember that absolute now I think
things are a little bit accelerated I
think it's you know we go through memes
very quickly he was quick to make fun of
it and I think I think that is just that
was just real my marketing oesophagus at
work but but it's it's we go through
them so fast and I think people jump on
him so quickly that his supporters are
sort of gonna have his back you know
what I mean and say like well it's not
fair for CNN it's called a career ender
he's probably the only Republican under
a hundred he's sort of good-looking this
is like their big hope if Watergate is
his undoing who else are they gonna like
shoved down our throats who else is
there
there's nobody no one else Jackie last
thought Britney Spears can come back
from flashing her vagina I like this guy
I'll be okay
you know the bummer about it is that you
know it distracted from the content of
the speech which was sort of hateful and
not a whole lot of her new ideas I
thought it was the ultimate distraction
because the speech had absolutely no
content anyway so it's like oh let me
water notice my god seemed like he was
like yeah and that is the funny stiff
part of politics that we all see all the
time like he kept looking at the camera
and yet leaning in in such a way like oh
no one's gonna see
what I'm about to do and yet we all
started alright we got to move on I
thought this one was interesting because
I know you three particularly are big
social media people all big on Twitter
particularly but a new study is showing
that people are exhausted when it comes
to Facebook 27% of Facebook users that
were just surveyed said they plan to
spend less time on Facebook in the next
year where do you guys fall out on this
social media thing are you exhausted has
it sucked the life out of you
Jacki we'll start with you no no I mean
I like Twitter a lot more it's just
easier and more fun I think but I like
that you can hide people now on Facebook
which is good from the timeline so you
can make it a little bit that's just
it's yeah yeah so it's a little less
exhausting Dave what do you think are
you following Tebow I fantasize about
deleting my Facebook account every
single day yeah I really do I'm sick to
death of it and if I didn't have the
thing if it I don't have shows to
promote yeah I would be gone I can't
handle it anymore I don't want to play
anything ville with you or anyone you
know you don't accept that here my
request is crazy I'm sick of being
tagged as a shoe I just I can't anymore
if you send me another bed bedazzled
Nike platform stiletto thing I really am
going to come to your house and punch
you because I can find out where you
live through some Facebook
that really made me crazy but how does
that happen like I can't get it off
their page well this is the heart of it
though it's interesting because we're
all talking about Facebook they're
saying about Facebook this sort of inner
world of your your friends with your mom
and then you know somebody that maybe
saw you do a comedy show or somebody
that has she requested you and you see
her and usually you just leave her Wow
that [ __ ] got blocked except your
mother she no see but that's how people
are that's how my mother is and that's
how my sister is they know what I'm
doing every moment of the day because
they are friends with all my friends who
drop dimes on me without that without a
blink of an eye Marcellus was out last
night making the ring either straight
making it rain at a strip club Marcellus
said blah blah blah blah blah more so
this is voting Republican it's like
literally you never know what's gonna
happen but Clarisse will call me up and
be like on Facebook you said how do you
know I blocked you well your friend
Tanika follows me and that's how I know
because she was with you I guess I got a
blocked Anika now Jackie what so do you
think Twitter is a little bit easier
because Twitter sorta more like one way
we're just putting stuff out there and
you can interact if you so choose but
it's not like your your personal life
is it you're a big foodie picture III
and I like to describe I like to
describe my pictures ever mind my food
in 140 characters or less I really do I
mean it's it's good it's it's it's a
good it's a good writers workout I did a
little little quiche with some some
sweet potato and mushrooms now the
question is have you change the evening
the process of eating you know what I
mean you cook you put together something
great you played it real nice yeah and
then the first thing is you got to take
a picture Instagram that's foreign food
for everyone oh my god you can't do
something you can't just lead a life
anymore without it being documented but
in 140 characters or by a picture yeah I
mean you had to come up with something
like it myself in 11 years because be
close to like Twitter what you know like
that's just it it's something if the
world ends how will I know it won't be
because the world is ending and the
buildings are falling down around me it
will be because Twitter will have let me
know you know but I'm going to get it
from the verified source like Gawker or
Huffington Post yeah so the question is
this what do we do if we're all feeling
this endless fatigue with all this stuff
but we can't stop it you haven't had a
private thought in 11 years you're
you're instagramming as we're as we're
sitting here what are we to do to
control the beast Jackie what do we do
just to control our endless again Big
Brother isn't it like they know
everything that we're doing and you know
instead of Big Brother we're like
actually being like we were here I was
there like we're doing it for them kind
of just makes [ __ ] so much easier
what do we do I don't know you can
delete your account you could turn your
friends into fans go to my fan page
you're my friend fan me they won't do I
heard of Dan Cook he turned his you know
friends into fit enough fans and friends
yeah so the opposite he turned his fans
into friends I did I change
the friends into fans thing and you get
a lot of people angry at you something
that I did for a little while which is
sort of like observe the Sabbath
in a way you know what I mean just
unplug like on a Sunday just no screens
yeah I mean close your laptop answer
phones on a calls on your phone and
that's it no texting no tweeting no
nothing and you know it makes you talk
to people in real life which is
unpleasant but well speaking of
unpleasant that brings us to our next
topic anger and expressing anger did you
know people it can lead you to a happier
life medical daily composted a study at
the University of Jena in Germany and it
revealed that being hot-tempered and
expressing your anger actually can add
years to your life we like to think oh
if you're you know somehow so evolved
and just pleasant and smiley all the
time that is the key to happiness but
know it's not the case how do you deal
with your anger there are so many places
I can go with this right now first I
love that it's the Germans notoriously
know about placing anger like doing this
study and you know I think they
mentioned in this study that it was the
Italians and the Spaniards live two
years longer than everyone else because
they're firey people and I was like
where do the black people fall right in
there cuz I'm the fiery ass of the fiery
people but I guess we're all being
killed out by each other really young so
our you know life rate goes down from
the moment we're bored but you're saying
this all with a smile on your face right
now so it's not born out of this anger
right I am an angry person I don't think
you could be a thinking sentient person
in this world without being angry about
something I will say I will probably
outlive everyone at this table and it
has nothing to do with my race but I do
verbalize my anger at all times I feel
it is part of my my journey and how I
protect myself to tell somebody that
they have pissed me off from the guy at
Kinkos who's not moving quick enough to
get me my copies too
the woman standing in line that's too
close behind me to Dave Rubin who you've
not made me angry yet but I'm yeah where
are you going with this by the end of
this I'll have come up with some reason
so yeah maybe I will be the guy that
lives to be 150 because I will tell you
you know immediately you just pissed me
off and I'm gonna tell you why now what
are you going to do to make me feel
better
Jackie what do you do is it comedy is
that how you get your also when I read
this article I it's like Free Willy it
wants to like run be free yeah I called
my father that I haven't talked to in 20
years and just like let him have it when
I read the article so I feel like you
know I'm like 10 years younger today
yeah exactly
Dave what about for you is it is a
comedy telling people jokes if you got
the angst out and I turn in where I'm
Irish Catholic so I'm I will be lucky to
survive through this broadcast yeah it's
yeah that's what we do we are we kind of
we push it down stuff it down and then
we have heart attacks when we learn you
know 43 so that's what we do I'm
thinking oh I I do I see a shrink now
and I try to you know I I talk about
things and I and I try to express anger
it still it feels very strange very
strange oh sure okay article a little
racially polarizing in the rain way when
they were talking the angry black man
but I mean and you know what add in the
angry black gay man and it really
becomes something different but I found
it a little something when they were
talking about the Spaniards and the
Italians and like they broke it down
racially and it was this like sort of
the calm serenus of the British and I
was like calm a serenus of the Brits I
mean what are you trying to say like I
believe they've been involved in a
couple of wars you know I I think it I
don't know have we gotten to the point
now where we're actually like looking
breaking down things racially and we're
saying like these people were calmer and
these because that stereotypes and that
only leads to
you know anger hey just just calm down
just calm down well what do you think I
just moved here to California where
everyone is smiling at me saying hello I
walk my dog down the street and people
are I'm starting to say hello to people
which is very uncomfortable for a New
York comedian leave in the car yes onto
the road yeah I've been pretty
controlled so far but what do you what
do you make of all these smiley happy
people here are they just sublimating it
or is this real here don't whether life
it's legal weed you know you're there
alone there are a lot of reasons I mean
it's just it's a good life what's not to
smile about the mountains you turn you
look there mountains everywhere you look
you know you're 20 minutes away from the
trees
all right you happy people the guns then
yeah let's muck this thing up these NRA
guys they did it again ladies and
gentlemen they keep putting out these
ads that in my opinion it seems to me
they're going so over-the-top with these
things well you know what just take a
look and then we'll knock it out so they
want a ban high-capacity magazines not
for the security that surrounds the
president Congress Mayor Bloomberg
Rockstar CEOs and wealthy big shots and
many drug cartels and home invading
killers will still get them from the
same black market that sells drugs
stolen cars and everything else that
criminals buy it's just the rest of us
with the law-abiding average people who
will have to defend our family
limited capacity magazines welcome to
the rock
middle-class okay where should we begin
my anger level just went up a little bit
I don't know about you guys you well
even you know seemingly even killed
Californians all right where do where do
we start with this a Dave I mean is this
just crazy over-the-topness there
there's there's a tiny kernel of truth
which is that criminals will continue to
acquire guns no matter what the laws are
we all know that that's okay but to
equate me or any person who can make it
to a gun show and by you know a hundred
bullet magazine or whatever with the
people who defend the President and the
Congress and rock stars and whatever
people who have had military training or
sniper training or whatever is
ridiculous and and and it's I feel like
people now are kind of they're they're
proud about their conceal and carry
permit everyone's really excited to
bring in gun places to like show up at
the movie theater with a gun because
just in case something breaks out
they're gonna turn into you know a
sniper and they're gonna take care of
business which no they're not has this
ever happened before has and I mean no
you know what did happen recently right
after the Aurora shooting a guy brought
a gun to a screening of a movie and it
fell out of his pocket he shot himself
in the ass shot himself this big dumb
ass that's what's gonna happen if you're
like best-case scenario is you're gonna
shoot your own ass yeah you know worst
case scenario you're gonna do it wrong
and you're gonna hurt an innocent
innocent person in front it's very silly
it's very silly they need they need to
they need to just relax just a tiny bit
yeah Jackie what do you what do you make
of these ads in the NRA and just their
their angle like it's totally like
trying to get the middle class like a
middle class running around guns like
you know like it ours and that and
statistically you know countries that
don't have you know people carrying
around guns so many fewer people are
being shot like that's just evidence
it's like proofs I don't understand
where they're going with all that yeah I
think one of the things that's
interesting here is that they're trying
to compare regular people as if our
defenses should be exactly the same as
the president or the mayor of New York
City as if we're under that kind of
threat are you walking around during
de feeling you're under the kind of
threat that President Obama is under do
you feel that angry black man tell me I
can't believe that I don't have like the
gun wielding entourage around me because
you know I'm verified on Twitter I got a
de minimis where is like my life you
know you know my ironclad team of my
multimillion-dollar guns shooting like
Posse with the whole thing where are
they by the way ladies and gentleman
this whole show was predicated and based
around that Marcellus at some point was
going to say that he was verified
Twitter on Twitter by the way Jackie and
I should have white guys heavily armed
uh-huh absolutely no you do not agree
that blue check you need it because
people want that check from you it
should come with the blue come with a
really sexy armbar yeah looks really
good in the armor but also looks equally
good out of armor yeah I'm paying for
that I'm paying for everything
can we get back to the point here there
was a point somewhere the thing that I
don't want to continue to be the angry
black bear but there's a thing at the
very end where they're like Obama's
middle class that actually just smacked
a little bit of like racism and I was
just like why does it have to be Obama
Smith went middle practically done the
reverse and everybody every baby that's
born in the operating room why you come
out you get a gun I guess that's what
the Republicans want us to think because
that's our right as Americans we should
be able to have a gun if we want to gun
the the truth is is you've got this
gun-toting class of people who are not
raising their children in the right way
and then their children take out their
irrational anger on other people so
they're the ones that are taking their
unlocked you know guns that are capable
of shooting ten thousand rounds in a
and going into schools and shooting
their friends or their enemies or
whoever they feel like or they're now
going into preschools and shooting
children because it's not just good
enough to go to high schools anymore and
kill children you have to go to it gets
younger and younger and younger yeah so
if you're going to talk to me about you
know this ability that you want to have
to get a gun
talk to me about what you're going to do
to make sure that those people that get
killed who are collateral damage don't
end up dead because of your right to
have a gun right it's not it's not
Obama's middle class effaces the problem
it is it is everyone's everything
everyone is contributed to it it is our
world right now that is a dangerous
place yeah do something about it Jackie
what do you think is going on in the NRA
meetings though when they come up with
this because we're pretty one of the
things that I'm really gonna try to do
here is bring on pretty you know
well-rounded people that aren't partisan
hacks on either side and yet anyone
that's watching this has got to be
thinking I mean this is just crazy so
what do they do just the messaging are
they what are they sitting there what
are they doing there they're just trying
to get the middle class to like really
want to protect themselves with guns and
that's never gonna happen like they're
not gonna be like we need guns to
protect ourselves from rock bands and
what rock bands are like running around
with like guns I've never heard of like
Motley Crue's like I think that was a
bit of a logic joke there but I said we
gotta move on this one
I'm really fascinated by this whole
thing so senator Bernie Sanders from
Vermont who is I think one of the
greatest politicians we have in the
country he's an independent which
automatically means he's completely
bonkers or at least if you watch Fox
News so he wrote an interesting piece on
Huffington Post about the Cayman Islands
and about how every corporation in this
country is sheltering money there you
thought it was just Mitt Romney no it's
every corporation from Citibank Bank of
America JPMorgan Chase Goldman Sachs
I mean billions and
and hundreds of billions of dollars
there is one building this I love this
there is one five-story office building
in the Cayman Islands that is home to
over 18,000 United States corporations
what do we what do we do about this what
do we do about these companies that we
bail out these big banks that then hide
the money what do we do just I guess
shame doesn't work
I guess literally that I guess when the
money is that high I guess that doesn't
work and that's the one thing that
drives me completely crazy I was one of
many things that drives me completely
crazy is that like you know if you speak
out against something if you're you know
this is the least timely reference of
all times but if you're the Dixie Chicks
and you say something about the Iraq war
you hate America and your records get
burned or whatever but if you take the
money that you make in America and you
move it out of America so that you don't
have to pay for anything in America
that's pretty hateful toward America I
think I mean that's pretty freeloader
ii-in terrorize so I don't they don't
make any records that we can burn but I
feel like that sort of need to call them
on some serious American that's even
farther with that America and Americans
ie the people sitting at this table and
the people that are watching helped to
bail you out of billions of dollars of
debt that you've accrued because you are
paying the top level of your bosses as
much money as they could possibly ever
spend in 10,000 lifetimes and you take
and after you've given that bailout when
you all should have been categorically
fired and in some cases taken out back
and shot when you are given this bailout
you don't come back with the repentant
heart you come back even hard or after
making more money in the past couple
years since that bailout then you may
before the bailout and you don't want to
pay taxes on that money so the tax
dollars that the Americans gave you the
government gave you to bail you out you
now don't even want to pay taxes on it's
unbelievable it is unbelievable but no
shame doesn't work
it's unbelievable and I found out my
banks part of it like should we do Bank
of America yeah yeah they're big let me
give you the numbers on Bank of America
so in 2010 they set up more than 200
subsidiaries in the Cayman Islands and
received a so they paid no taxes right
in the first place no US taxes and then
the IRS their rebate was 1.9 billion
dollars that's what Abby's not with an
EM so okay if shames not gonna work and
logic isn't gonna work what what is it
is there really nothing that can work
you know we all talk about this stuff
but is there nothing that can work
because I hate to say it but because the
system is rigged I mean we send in
politicians that are bought and paid for
we all we all know this stuff so is
there really nothing we can do when it
when stuff gets this so above where
regular people all right I guess take
your money and put it in a credit union
right if everybody got together and did
that it will I think it's about us
taking our money and you know starting
Marcel lachemann is calm at one of these
offices in the Cayman Islands and we
have to do what everybody else is doing
if everybody else is doing it we should
do it I mean literally I mean then I
mean I guess it's like everybody starts
you know bilking the government out of
money then they will actually move to
legislate that you know what you can't
take your money out of the United States
when you make your money here you have
to pay taxes on everything do you guys
think there's something just so
ingrained about how you can get away
with this for example not to bring
everything back to in my opinion the
worst can that it ever Mitt Romney but
he had money hidden in the Cayman
Islands and and that didn't disqualify
him automatically I mean it was legal
but shouldn't that just morally and in
light of the economy and everything else
shouldn't that have just disqualified
the guy just like that that there should
have been a meeting and they had said
you know well you got this money there
so just that uh we're gonna go a
different direction
no I think he would have taken it out
before he started running like that
would be something I would do right away
you know no cuz that wouldn't mean he
would had to bring it back here and he
would actually had to pay taxes are
there and he would have had to actually
that's more shameful right he would have
had to release the fact that he had been
not paying taxes for her for many years
and today the thing that I never
understood about Mitt Romney and that
base of people that was really liked
about him was he was probably one of the
most elitist candidates to ever run ever
and how was he gonna how was the man
with the money in the Cayman Islands
gonna even care about the guy in the
Appalachian Mountains who has no shoes
but that guy wouldn't even think of
voting for Obama 47% that is the answer
there's it's I don't like what Mitt
Romney did with his money but it is
legal you said it I mean it's not it's
gross it's not ethical
but it's legal what he did he was just
following rules and and maximizing the
amount of his own money that he was able
to keep fine I don't like it but that's
fine I wish that they the people who
defended him would have the same amount
of compassion for the 47% that don't pay
federal income taxes because it's not
like they're living high off the hog
they are also following the rules they
are also paying payroll taxes they are
also contributing but they are also
playing by the rules you know I mean but
but it seemed like everybody who was
probed Mitt Romney vilified that
percentage of the country yeah I mean
absolutely it's the same thing yeah I
mean obviously on his much much higher
what is Mitt Romney doing with all his
money in the Cayman Islands like I
understand what like you know George
Clooney is doing with his money and
they'd be like real rich people that
like are going on bang and like Stacy
Keibler doing you know high-end things I
know what P Diddy is doing with his
money because he's got the guards and
he's got the big cars but what is Mitt
Romney doing with his money in the
Cayman Islands what he is working it's a
new vodka brand his money is just
working for him that's what it's you
know if they're not like us where we
work and we put money in a bank and then
we have to spend that money like you're
working for them billion dollar shopping
sprees and buy and they got and like you
know does he
like a couple of like really
good-looking like Asian girls and a
house somewhere they just service him
and that's all the signs like what are
you doing yeah buddy this you can't pay
taxes on any united states Mitt Romney
he's hoarding them and the Cayman
Islands too you know what we're just
gonna go with that rumor he's a budget
he has a bunch of Asian women that well
let's talk about something that you can
do with your money if you if you have
some money robots people they are coming
I'm excited about this story there is
going to be the first advanced humanoid
robot it's about nine months off it is
going to feel like a human being it's
gonna be a service robot it's going to
be accessible to the public not just to
the super-rich so robots are coming this
is this is the science-fiction dream
that everyone has had for a long time so
I guess where to start with this how
long will it take for them to become our
overlords Jackie yeah I'm wondering how
long it's gonna take till there's porn
with the robots and that's that dog that
actually moves and speaks when she's
being
Marsellus has been waiting for the male
version talking about how we can't stop
taking pictures of our food for five
minutes they are our overlords alright
book yeah the robots rulers yes
this rules me it's the last thing I
touched before I go to bed the first
thing I touch on a roll up in the
morning yes and my cell phone we are all
slaves to something with circuitry into
the data I find this really creepy and
what I find even creepier is that don't
these people watch movies didn't you see
iRobot with Will Smith yeah you see that
didn't end well didn't you see
artificial intelligence with that creepy
little guy from The Sixth Sense that
really didn't end well cuz at the end
the only people are left are him the
little creepy teddy bear and the aliens
that come down and they're like oh the
earth is now cold and barren in there
are no humans left a lot of people's
doing like
it was a bad ending I'm with you it was
an awful ending it can't end well this
will not end well this will end with
like some old lady being choked by a
robot this will end with like some guy
like finding himself like finding a way
to like impale a robot and being
electrocuted to death this won't anyway
okay now I agree with you I agree with
you the robot thing and not you're
really good in the kick out is the most
whimsical bad ending of all time like it
is gonna end badly but it's gonna be
like that really bad Bruce Willis Lee
he's gonna be like the Cabbage Patch
things were a thing yeah rolling around
like Cabbage Patch dolls in their things
and they were actually naming them and
they were talking to them people are
going to stop talking to each other and
they're going to have the idyllic child
who happens to be a robot who actually
has blue eyes and blonde hair cuz I
probably have a little robot kid that
had blue eyes and blonde hair cuz I mean
little black girls and having to comb
their hair and stuff so anyway you're
rolling around with this doll and you're
not interacting with anybody you've got
your perfect robot baby and if you're me
you've got your perfect robot husband
who has like a six-pack abs and is like
six foot two and it's perfect and he
does whatever you want to do and there's
no backtalk and there's no where's the
credit card I want to go shopping this
will not end well people this is the
beginning of the apocalypse and it's a
robot apocalypse like Darth Vader Lee
when I selected this story I really had
no idea that it was this level they're
making them for when you know you're
growing old when you're you know so
you're by yourself you're already in a
nursing home
the only person is gonna be taking care
of you as a robot like it's not even a
person the oh you're saying are you
saying that's bad
but no is this just because we all think
for some reason that these things
because of science fiction movies we all
think automatically this is just gonna
be all hell is gonna break loose when in
reality maybe a nice Oprah robot nice
human contact about my mama a robot
instead of like the purse she wants for
Christmas now I'm supposed to buy her a
robot also and that makes me a bad [ __ ]
if I do do that who's gonna buy an old
person a robot it's going to be rich
people buying robots so that they don't
have to do anything they're gonna be
slaves it's gonna be a bunch of freaky
people who can't get a woman to do what
they want
buying robots it's going to be a bunch
of people who kill a bear in buying
little robot kids and talking to them
like they're action real people this
will not end it's gonna be you know what
it's gonna be like I'm gonna make a
robot of myself so that I don't have to
leave the house and it's gonna be like
that bad Bruce Willis movie Wow where
they're like you know you're fat you're
morbid in your house bound because all
you do all day is eat and you've got
this thing on your head that makes your
robot go to work for you and your robot
is an idealized version of you
so my robot now looks like Tyson
Beckford and is like you know buff and I
get to sit at home and do nothing but
eat Oreo and frozen Reese's Cups I think
we I'm pretty sure we just ended the
show Dave we have anything else you'd
like to possibly top it all right
Marcellus hold yourself for one second I
want to remind you guys that my wardrobe
is brought to you by bonobos calm and
you can enter code Reuben report to get
20% off your next order they got shirts
they got past they got shoes they got
underwear they got socks
all stuff for humans and for robots
alike that's right I want to thank
Marcellus Reynolds Jacki Monahan Dave
Holmes and I'm gonna let you guys pimp
yourselves out because I always feel
that the guests on these shows can give
a more intimate pimping than the hosts
Marcel's where can people find you
merciless riddles calm well tomorrow
morning I will be selling robot
apocalypse t-shirts a man moves quick
Jackie you can go to Twitter Jackie
mañana Twitter and Facebook of course
and Jackie Monahan calm and you can go
on itunes and order my movie codependent
lesbian space aliens seeks aim high you
can find me on Twitter at Dave Holmes I
am verified an auto brag and I'll also
be appearing at The Upright Citizens
Brigade la this Thursday the 21st a 9:30
extra Los Angeles cool well I thank you
guys for joining me on the first episode
of the Reuben report watch out for those
rich gun-toting robots everybody we will
see you next week thank you